I'm going to bring out our panel and let
you guys hear what they have to say
first we have executive producer Ali
Adler
we have Supergirl herself
Melissa Benoist mr. McCotter us
miss Kyle early
David Harewood
Jeremy Jordan executive producer Sarah
Schecter executive producer Andrew
Kreisberg and executive producer Greg
Berlanti all right okay
choose the executive producers oh and
and Oh mr. Jeff John all right
okay so Jeff and food producers of all
the DC Comics properties that are
available on wide Supergirl it's time
isn't it it has been discussed in at
length and in the media that it is very
difficult to launch a female superhero
either on the small screen or on the big
screen what makes this story so
universally appealing and and right now
I think for us it was a story that
needed to be told and I think that she
is you come in and you see her as female
and you'll go out and you'll remember
her as powerful and so her gender
doesn't really matter she's a badass
and Greg Greg and Jeff both of us for
both of you have spoken about how
important it was to have women involved
in the development of this show and the
production of it talk a little bit about
that well first it's important that
we're involved in every show in
production but I know like when we first
started talking about Supergirl
the whole reason it was different and
new and and something I get so far past
time have a female superhero lead show
and it really again it took Greg and
everybody else but really great came in
with a very specific vision
cuz there was a lot discussion about how
do we do it and Greg rightly so said we
do write we do exactly like the comic
books which makes me happy I had that
and Drake me but I talked more to a
while you thought this was the best one
yeah I just I was really excited to
participate in something like this I
mean III think the Superman and
Supergirl mythology is in a lot of ways
the most famous mythology in all comic
books and so you know we wanted to do
that justice and that s justice and then
ya also I've been really lucky enough as
we've talked about tonight to
participate in shows with a lot of male
leads at the center and it just felt
like it was time for a female lead at
the center of one of these shows and
and you know you get opportunities to do
those things and you feel like you shame
if you didn't take the opportunity you
had to participate in something like
that and then you know those things they
take on a life of their own
you get Ali and Sarah participating you
get Jeff and Andrew participating and
then finally the cast really comes on
board and you meet Melissa Benoist and
you can't imagine anybody else being
Supergirl it's really incredibly hot so
okay about that yeah I need to talk
about that because I mean you guys are
going to love her so much
what was it that when when she showed up
what was it that told you okay this girl
needs to be in a cape one of the most
amazing things for us was we saw in
David rapport you know the most
brilliant casting the parent had we are
privileged to work with but what was so
exciting was we saw thousands of women
and this is the first one we saw yeah we
have to actually give a shout out to
David rapport and Lindsey ball Sarah who
are casting directors yeah these are
this is true story Stephen Amell with
literally me very first person we saw
for Oliver Queen and Grant Gustin was
the very first person we saw for for
Barry Allen and Melissa was the very
first person we saw for Cara so you know
Dave rapport and we do balls care really
uh certainly know our taste they know
how to find the best superheroes but
when I get that Melissa left the room we
all look at each other in new because we
weren't interested in doing the show
unless we found someone that was good
enough and had all of the colors and
once Willis audition we kind of thought
it'd be easy and then we saw thousands
of people and there's only one super
girls and that is most of the noise
I can't agree enough I'm sorry this is
such a super Ven
Melissa how intimidating is that though
well I'm sitting here listening to
everyone and I remember leaving my first
audition being like oh my gosh I just
blew it you know um yeah it's a
wonderful thing here you guys family's
nicely and intelligent when you first
put on the costume oh man
yep that is a kind of it's hard to
articulate the way that that feels um it
feels you know I'm putting on tights and
I'm it feels like I'm putting on
something like I used to when I took
dance class but then you get the cape
and then I turn around and I look in the
mirror and I see the S and something
clicks inside and there's it just really
does transform internally it's hard it's
impossible not to feel empowered and to
feel hope and strength and brave when
I'm wearing it I feel like a different
person and the great thing is also is
when you guys see the pilot after this
you will understand that it's not just
that Melissa is playing a strong female
character there are several strong
female characters in Kyler's your
character is equally well defined and
written but the thing that I found so
immediately striking was that you guys
seemed to have a very sisterly bond off
the bat you know I I gosh about her a
lot oh I love this girl is one of those
incredible things when you you meet
somebody especially somebody that you're
gonna work with that you just get it and
I really feel like it was almost
instantaneous between have to go that
definite and it's just it's really
special and I love her and I'm so proud
of her and and it's it's it's really
really it's very humbling it's very
exciting
out of it and I'm still freaking out is
Harvey and David um without spoiling
because I want you guys to see this but
your character is it's kind of hard to
get a read on this guy I can't tell if
he's a good guy who's bad with people or
if he's a bad guy
I think I think that's pretty good I
like to keep people guessing mm-hmm so
the gray area I think is where where
this character exists
you don't quite know exactly who he is
it is if he's got good intentions or bad
intentions I think you're just gonna
have to wait and see okay Jeremy again
in this in this pilot I feel like
there's room for romance between your
character and losses um but what do you
think it takes to sweep the Girl of
Steel off her feet well I think that mom
my character who win is kind of in love
with Cara before he finds out that she's
Supergirl and maybe that's the key I
don't know loving her for who she really
is but uh but you know there's the the
revelation happens and there's another
very strong attractive male standing the
best mm-hmm strong attractive me I'll be
in the cod Rose haha I don't know okay
so God as a lot of you probably know is
playing James Olsen who's all grown up
and here to kind of start as like a Jedi
Master
so our heroine um this guy what's his
story now uh James comes from metropolis
to National City uh I can't say that he
uh he he comes because he wants to okay
are you
all right i'ma stop ensues after that if
any of you were here for last year's big
Saturday night were you here okay you
might remember an iconic moment where
Stephen Amell revealed his abs and I
find hahahaha I find that the challenge
has been put there to see if we possibly
have abs of steel here
Gervin Couric no oh no no no I'm close
yes all about me we got together do show
hands behind the bases what what is that
yeah I think we should do it you are all
local are you wearing on all right thank
you
I feel really violated and um what
happens in all the countries on Twitter
I'm all follows me a lot of moms are
gonna follow you now I so to the cursor
so guys love to weave in other DC
characters you have anyone on deck that
you are ready to announce uh well I
would love to announce this we have
amazing villains for Cara and everyone
coming up but we hope to be with getting
the season reactron and livewire nice
hello hello
no there's one more oh yeah I know if
you guys are familiar with Maxwell Lord
okay well he's kind of complicated
because he's kind of good sometimes bad
what kind are we gonna see here I mean
would you guys just want to meet him how
do we yeah yeah
last time I was here whispered Twilight
so it's good to be home and I'm super
excited to be on his show come on oh
honey that was funny all right well now
you see it for the producer is one last
question before we go what can you tell
us about the tone of this show what can
you tell them I know what it is and it's
beautiful but let's explain to them what
they're about to see um I think it's uh
you know we were heavily influenced by
the Donner vision for Superman and it's
it's it's show it's grounded and and fun
and full of heart and humor but you know
more than anything and that's honestly
it's truthfully group you know Melissa's
greatest superpower is is to make you
believe in her and you know this is
really a show about a hero that you can
believe in and someone who can make you
proud and make you feel alive and make
you feel like you want to be a better
person
and you know we really feel like this is
the kind of show that everyone can watch
together families can watch together and
can really be something to bring some
light into the world all right well you
guys get ready to fall in love and let's
thank all these guys we will see them
probably next summer I think so your
your you're committed to this whole
superhero thing right definitely yeah
all right well yeah because I could hook
you up with the guy pretty sweet vampire
gig if you want upset but what if your
ever National City crossover man
now well and you've been to comic-con
before this is my first time is is that
what always happens at the end of a
panel well this is a very very special
night and we are clearing all of this
off because we're going to get in extra
super performance by Lucent dossier to
celebrate the world of DC superheroes
and then to end the night please enjoy
the Supergirl pilots we are all super
proud of it's thank you thank you
you